e aí
e eu tenho uma grande paixão que a
entender como a qualidade dos
relacionamentos afetam a saúde das
pessoas é isso que eu estudo há mais de
30 anos
é uma das coisas que eu aprendi por
exemplo é que o imprevisto pode ajudar
no desenvolvimento da saúde isso eu
aprendi com palhaços que atuam no
hospital o grupo que eu estudei aí por
20 anos doutores da alegria trabalha com
a técnica do improviso a improvisação é
habilidade de poder incorporar os fatos
que estão acontecendo naquele momento
para desenvolver o jogo ea relação com a
criança
e é também do improviso que nasce a
graça
e quando a existe essa relação por
exemplo que palhaços tá nessa interação
por exemplo se tá passando um carrinho
levando a comida no corredor do hospital
e aquilo aquele som pode virar o som de
um trem e esse trem pode levar o artista
e a criança para uma viagem para
transilvânia por exemplo
e a graça que nasce também do inesperado
é interessante é como se ela passasse
uma rasteira no nosso intelecto na nossa
razão e o surpreendesse isso nos faz
rico
e a graça também ela está associada a
uma compaixão de deus divina que desce
sobre os homens e também delicadeza das
formas então existe na graça algo de
divino o seu significado é
e depois de muitos anos estudando vendo
pacientes acamados estudando a interação
entre palhaços e crianças vendo muitas
interações estudando sobre o imprevisto
ea improvisação do dia primeiro.de
fevereiro de 2017 algo perfeitamente
possível na verdade qualquer um
aconteceu comigo porém totalmente
inusitado para mim eu e minha família
nesse dia voltarmos de viagem de férias
na via dutra quando o senhor que nos
conduzia teve um infarto perdeu o
controle da direção e bateu contra uma
mureta
é a minha filha quebrou o fêmur namorado
dela foi para uma cirurgia de emergência
por ter rompido o baço e o meu filho
menor sofreu escoriações leves e eu eu
acordei 23 dias depois numa uti
é uma das primeiras palavras que eu
escutei quando eu acordei e foi
sobrevivente eu demorei muito tempo para
entender o significado dessa palavra e
muitos meses para remontar a história
que eu vou contar agora para vocês
hoje eu acordei eu tinha dois ferros
atravessando a minha bacia um de cada
lado eu tinha as mãos em fachadas porque
o carro pegou fogo e queimou parte das
minhas mãos
e eu tinha estava entubada tava sem voz
tinha catéteres e tubos passando por mim
tinha mais de 50 fraturas no corpo e
sete costelas novas de titânio
é mas o que me tinha claro muita dor
nesse nessa nessa fase mas o que me
chamou mesmo atenção nesses primeiros
dias porque apesar de tudo isso daí
mobilidade das dores a minha percepção
estava extremamente aguçada
e eu rapidamente entender entende para
quais profissionais quais profissionais
estavam abertos para interagir comigo e
me ajudar no que naquele momento era
essencial para mim era essencial que me
virar sem com delicadeza para minimizar
agora era essencial que molhasse a minha
boca com uma gaze para aplacar a sede
era essencial que a novalgina fosse
injetada devagar para evitar as fotos
fortes taquicardias
e é incrível que o corpo humano faz pela
sobrevivência
o e apesar de eu sentir ali o hálito da
morte naquela uti eu me sentia
extremamente viva apesar do entra e sai
de pessoas naquele lugar sem dia nem
noite porque não tinha janelas algo
acontecia
bom e foi a partir daí que eu comecei a
viver os meus cem dias de hospital e a
recomeçar e me transformar mas por onde
começar
e eu lembro que nos primeiros dias dois
fisioterapeutas que me acompanhavam já
há algum tempo vieram me visitar e um
deles falou para mim mexe os olhos mecha
língua méxico que dá
oi e eu pensei é isso a vida o fio da
vida a gente segura por onde da e eu
tinha ali alguns fios por onde eu ia
recomeçar a minha a minha jornada
naquele hospital
eu descobri também nessa época que
existe uma potência na fragilidade
e essa potência eu vivi ela mesmo antes
de acordar durante o coma eu tive uma
série de 20 sonhos nos quais eu lembro
nitidamente e eu pude começar a
registrar oito meses depois do acidente
quando as minhas mãos permitiram esses
sonhos eram extremamente nítidos neles
eu tava em hospitais muito bonitos
hospitais alocados em lugares desérticos
hospitais barco hospitais casa
é mas que me chamou atenção nesse sonhos
recordando de deles é que apesar de eu
estar em coma muitas coisas que eu
sonhei de fato tinham acontecido
e por exemplo eu sonhei com a minha
filha de muletas vindo na minha direção
e tentando me ajudar a levantar porque
nesses sonhos eu tava sempre imobilizada
ou numa maca ou numa cadeira de rodas
ela vinha e tentava me ajudar a levantar
e quando ela vir ela escorregava e caia
e aí depois do meu marido me telefonava
e dizia que ela tinha que ser recuperada
em função da queda e de fato a minha
filha foi operada do fêmur e teve que
ser operada no período que eu tava em
coma em outro sonho por exemplo eu
estava sendo transportada em um
helicóptero e isso de fato aconteceu eu
fui transportada do interior de são
paulo para aqui para o rio de janeiro
nos primeiros dias em outro sonho eu
estava sendo conduzida para fazer uma
cirurgia e meu marido me contava com meu
filho tinha queimado as mãos
e na verdade eu tinha queimado as mãos
eu fiz várias cirurgias uma delas para
amputar parte dos dedos da mão
o que força é essa que se manifestava
apesar da imobilidade né existem várias
explicações para esse sonhos fontes de
conhecimento diferentes mas o que eu
queria ressaltar aqui o que é importante
para mim é contar que esse sonhos me
ajudaram no momento que eu acordei
ajudaram na minha recuperação ajudaram
por exemplo eu escutar com uma certa
serenidade a história que meu marido me
contou logo que eu acordei
bom então foi assim com essa força da
fragilidade que eu comecei a viver os
primeiros dias no hospital
oi hoje e refletindo sobre essa
experiência e pensando nessa questão da
força da fragilidade é eu entendi que
apesar de eu ser psicóloga trabalhar
muitos anos vendo pacientes
hospitalizados existe em mim uma certa
dó diante deles uma certa comiseração eu
deixei isso embora larguei isso e
comecei a entender a força que existia
nessa fragilidade hoje eu diria para
pessoas que cuidam dos seus pacientes
não se engane pela aparência deles
talvez eles podem estar muito mais vivos
do que você imagina cabe a nós puxar o
fio de vida para ajudá-los na
recuperação
é bom vivendo os primeiros do hospital
que acontece que coisas eu aprendi a
primeira coisa que você perde quando
você tá no hospital é o pudor o pudor
não serve a nada as pessoas entram e
saem precisão fazer procedimentos em
você precisa um tiro desnudar precisão
lutar pela sua vida então a deus vou por
o eu também tive que mudar completamente
a ordem as prioridades na minha vida
logo que eu acordei uma voz gritava
dentro de mim eu me perguntava mais como
eu não tô do lado dos meus filhos para
cuidar deles nesse momento mas eu
comecei a entender que eu tinha que
focar em mim e na minha recuperação para
poder novamente do lado deles
e outra coisa que acontece no hospital é
que o tempo tem mais tempo ali e
imobilizada eu tinha mais tempo para o
que acontecia e muitas pessoas que
estavam dispostas a interação também
tenho mais tempo o tempo se dilata
pessoas que eu jamais imaginei vieram me
visitar e ficar comigo abriram tempo no
tempo delas para poder tá ali isso faz
com que a minha memória se povoou e de
lembranças muito boas do hospital diante
de uma situação trágica podem se abrir
momento de extrema beleza eu nunca vou
esquecer por exemplo o primeiro banho
que eu tomei no hospital depois de 4
meses sendo banhado leito e eu pude
sentir água escorrendo em mim
e do chuveiro de cadeira de roda e isso
era delicioso dava gritos de felicidade
assim como nos últimos dias quando me
levaram para uma área externa do
hospital e eu podia sentir a brisa
roçando a minha pele pequenos
acontecimentos ganhavam uma outra
dimensão
o poder tá aqui agora conversando com
vocês é muito especial isso não é só uma
maneira de dizer é a pura verdade hoje
eu convivo com duas linhas do tempo a
linha do tempo do que tá existindo agora
de poder tá aqui com vocês trocando
idéias e eu tenho consciência de uma
outra linha do tempo onde isso poderia
perfeitamente não tá acontecendo
é uma série de eventos acontecerão para
que eu pudesse tá aqui agora um
caminhoneiro de seu do seu carro pegou
seu instrutor e apagou o fogo do nosso
carro quanto pegava fogo pessoas vieram
nos retiraram de lá pessoas nos
transportaram para o hospital o primeiro
cirurgião que me operou colocou meus
órgãos no lugar no segundo o cirurgião
que fechou a minha bacia e conteve o
sangramento quero meu grande risco de
morte nos primeiros dias e todas as
pessoas que trabalharam a seis cirurgias
que se seguiram as enfermeiras os
médicos auxiliares de enfermagem as
pessoas da limpeza amigos que vieram é
uma lista enorme de pessoas que me
ensinaram o valor da palavra gratidão
e muitas dessas pessoas eu não conheço
talvez nunca conheça mas a minha vida
está extremamente entrelaçada delas
é a minha agenda de 2017 tá vazia no
mundo produtivo do trabalho foi um ano
que eu não existir nenhuma viagem
nenhuma reunião nada e o maior número de
horas que eu passei imobilizada mas a
despeito de tudo isso foi um ano de
enormes aprendizados enormes
transformações e grandes encontros
e hoje eu sou uma pessoa mais feliz mais
aberta para o mundo e apesar das
sequelas físicas eu vivo em um corpo
mais saudável
e durante esse período eu produzi um
diário eu gostaria de ler um pequeno
trecho para vocês
e aí
é um dia o ladrão ladrão desculpa um dia
o dragão te lambe com suas labaredas
você queima e se reduz a cinzas então a
partir daí talvez algo inédito possa
acontecer eu galo pena natureza da luta
pela vida pude sentir cada momento de
imposição de sobrevivência ela pode ser
feroz assustadora e também fascinante e
mágica nasce das suas entranhas e pulso
enquanto as máquinas apitam e apresentam
o teu corpo na imobilidade
eu falo de um percurso essencial
respirar urinar defecar se arrastar pelo
chão e depois de alguns meses engatinhar
andar esses verbos carregam a dimensão
da vida acontecimento sutis podem ser
sinônimos de estado de graça e você se
sente novamente alinhado com a
existência e durante algum tempo você
vive um milagre de perceber as camadas
da vida
e as camadas que pulsam nos pequenos do
acontecimentos e abrir os olhos ao
amanhecer deixa de ser trivial ele é um
pequeno milagre que se repete a cada dia
continuar conectada a magia de abrir os
olhos de senti a água ea brisa você luta
para manter essas lembranças vivas na
memória e essa torna-se uma batalha tão
sangrenta quanto aquela da uti as
lembranças dos momentos de mobilidade
doença chegam a ser perturbadoras não
tanto por suas dores físicas e
emocionais mas sim por seus momentos de
beleza a beleza pela qual luto para que
ela não se apague no corredor longo e
estreito do cotidiano muito obrigado por
me ajudarem a não esquecer
e aí